這就是了ATR船,
一個名字 turboprop船,
但它有很混互的名字,
尤其是在海洋艦。
回到我去看,
去簽了一簽約去海洋艦隊的合作
啊…
是…
船,
它可以是很驚訝
你明白了很古俗的和明天,
這個飛機是
今天,我們先看看這個
這個禮物的ATR
我們是在這次航空的ATR
我們有這個ATR72600
這是一個普通的ATR
和一個普通的
500的這個面子是比較多的
是比較多的
而且應該會比較多的
是的,這個就是
這個動作的ATR
這是一個非常新的航空
而這個機器
和它們的機器
也不完全比
AIRBUS航空機,也許是,你也聽到很多媒體,因為它是因為它們的大量,
因為它們是因為它們的大量,但因為它們都會 crash,
現在是那些嗎?
可能是,我不會說這一個船航空機,
但它們的碼碰到達到0.44%的距離,
在這裏,並不太好,
例如,它們的駕駛有一個AIRBUSA300,
但但仍然是,A300不太多的航空
它是稍微不足以保持的DC9
很高的航空
而是相比的737,它是雙倍的
但仍然是不足以保持的
但仍然是很高的高度
因此,它是不足以保持的
所以,在新的新的新的新型格
是不足以保持的
但那是因为这列列的
快速破产的车回产
整個歧視的歧視都會從 1988
而且你也知道這船是有點複雜的
因為它們都在同時
而且這件事是因為這些歧視是因為有些是因為這些升降機的改造我們會在一會兒再次測試一下我們可以說這車子也會用的
是一會兒像來自動的風格
但這次會有更多的問題
那一定會提出錯誤
對,很多這些升降機都會適合
我們現在都是在這次的系統
這次又是一種比較新的版本
它對有相同的標準
那是一開始
I guess the 500 once again is not as modern
I wonder if I can just simply turn on this airplane
Let's start A and B
Start in 1
See if that works
On
Let's put the condition lever to what?
Auto
Yes and that works
You can see the left engine turn on
Yes this is the modern version of the ATR with modern engines
At least they don't fail all the time
That is good
But here you can see a little bit of a design flaw already
See the condition levers
Which to simply explain it are levers
which you can simply turn off the fuel for the engine,
are right next to the flap lever,
which can be a bit of a danger,
accidentally turning off the engine when you want to set the flaps down.
Now,you may remember what happened on the Swift Air 737,
where pilots accidentally turned off the hydraulics by switching the wrong switch,
and well,this design choice has killed people.
For example,NVETI Airlines Flight 691,
which happened in 2023,not too long ago at all,
where the pilots accidentally changed the position of both condition levers
to the feathered position which resulted in the loss of thrust leading to the aerodynamic stall
and crash where the captain called flaps 30 but the first officer didn't put the flap letter to 30
but put the engine to feather which means off practically and now we shut down there you go
still working so yes an inherent failed design maybe although i think it would be very hard to
confuse the two levers to be honest either way let's go ahead and start taxing here and well
你认识,这不是很大的船,它是很大的船,而且它是很大,但是它们都会有很多船上,所以他们可能不太好
现在,我们现在的船上,我现在不想让它们尽力,它们是不太好,但不一定不坦能做的看来,这些是这些,那是一样的一样的船上,我们现在的船上you know unsafe or anything it is safe but definitely not flawless come on let's do ityeah see this yeah that was kind of a tail strike that happens come on go full power i need more
fout i need more power yes now landing gear up that works well it's quite a reliable landing
gear i mean compared to the q400 which has like landing gear issues every three months atr doesn't
have that good there we go taking oh taking off come on all is fine let's go ahead and turn on
AutoPilot, which sure is not as sophisticated as your modern Airbus Autopilot, this plane
does NOT have autothrottle.
So what it also doesn't have is Autoland in any way.
It can't land itself, but all those stuff make this plane a higher workload.
Anyway, it is flying, for now.
But look at this, on the 600 we have a touch screen, which works well.
But something you wouldn't want to encounter with the ATR is icing conditions, which we
can do, I think here.
Oh no, icing.
有一個營造型,我可以去做一下,我們要把那一天,我們要把那一天變成。
我告訴你,我們要把那一切。
來,我們要把這一次的一切。
快。
好,入炸地,我們要把它切成。
你會看到一切。
我們可以看到一切。
我們看到一切,我們要把那一切。
我們來,我們現在的一切。
空中,轉一次一切。
我們去做一切。
我們現在的一切。
我們要把一切。
我們將會失去。
我們可以見到一切。
我們來自於是,我們要把一切。
在几次上,有些遇到有机会发现了,因为它是在一起的有机会发生,
也就是在这个月前,我们也都知道,
过去Vopass Flight 2283,
空编过来,跑出车的机会,
因为的有机会发生,因为它被机会发生了,
因为,可能,受机会发生了,
同时,同时,在美国Eagle Flight 4184,
很久以前,1994,
能看到它现在,正在机会发生了,
是用的地衣服的衣服,
在衣服上的位置,
那是在衣服的衣服,
在衣服上的衣服,
不是用烤衣服,
像像像像海洋船船,
那是衣服的衣服,
而是用的衣服,
而我认为,可能是更加弱的衣服,也不是很不确,但是,我们都看到了很多衣服,但我们都是也就是不太乱了但是,我们还看到了很多球语,我们都看到了Q400的同时,但是也就是一些东西,可能是不太乱了
在ATR
我们还有一点点的衣服,这些车子飞了很悲惨
我们很高的我们都很高的速度
我们可以做什么ATR能做
那就是要乱上车车的车车
We have reverse thrust, we've got a plane that can fly at lower speeds, this is nice
This is why pilots have mostly a hate love relationship with this plane
It's not that bad, you get good at riding up MELs
So things are broken all the time, minimum equipmentless
Packs are horrible, that is for like air conditioning
Radar sucks, especially on the 500
Seat is uncomfortable, bang your head on everything if you're an inch over 511
Slow, unreliable, and autopilot that has tried to kill me more than students
No assist cable controls, wow
But overall she's easy and a fun bird to fly
所以这就是一个非常软件的航空
它们有些软件的系统
它们可能会被捞到
但是它们没有安全
比任何其他软件的航空
并且它们没有任何强性
但如果你是学习的航空
你应该要选择了
E320
Either way
来吧
我愛你的光臨,你會用它
藍色的,這個機器是
這部機器是一部機器的
我認識的機器是
可以用到重量的
在迫射擊,你會做到
不停的,不停的,不停的
不停的,不停的
有,我們可以停止
在零時的時間
真是,那是,那會有完全
破壞了,但這就是很棒
我希望大家有多多多了
我會不會,好久不見
特別感謝大家,我的支持
我的支持
Gunskiller,R27,JamesDaram,ThatDude
AnimeGodsOfGaming,Derek
Insiderplane,NishijitsuFinder
ProfessionalJamal,RylandWilliams
And NewTheYork
You've got beautiful names